tell us a little about yourself I
decided what I want to tell a contest
that maybe I give it a go in Hollywood
the Virgin were allies emerged some guys
never stopped looking to hide the salami
what do the deed dip the wick butter the
muffin I get it hi I'm Frank hi two
weeks in Los Angeles you're working for
Howard Hughes no harm having high hopes
ma'am four hundred dollars a week on top
of it while I've heard about Howard
Hughes I hope he does inspect it meet
you in some hotel room mr. Hughes I'd
like to thank you for my acting classes
thank you for my ballet classes and
thank you for the chance to become a
star tell is she doing here you said you
wanted to grow up with the two ends yes
Marilyn Monroe ah that's Marlon Avery
she's at Baptist none you do know why
that just think sex is bad no yeah cuz
it might lead to dancing maybe I'm not
the right girl for this I'm a square
movie actress should have big bosoms of
me sexy mean in this town aren't those
the rules
you're an exception the rules that apply
to you told my friend I was terribly was
it far too late to do my fiance believes
that once you've been intimate and the
eyes of god you're committed to that
person for the rest of your life so she
believes that you're already married if
anybody working for me wants to strike
up a relationship with one of our
contract actresses I have to fire what
are you doing you've got a driver's
license don't you let's go
have you heard from people that I'm
crazy
you're not like other people you're an
exception something we didn't plan on
has happened
did somebody give that to
who gave that to
you are gifted young woman with a
wonderful future nobody's getting any
younger when you told me the rules don't
apply to me you know they don't applied
you neither
working for Howard Hughes no harm having
high hopes ma'am and what church do you
go to frame First Methodist and Fresno I
forgive you she's giving we're back